I had intended to make this video on you
know the first of January but I was on a
Christmas break then and I sort of just
delved into a routine of laziness but
we're still close enough to talk about I
think some New Year's resolutions and
the ones I'll share with you today will
be the ones related to my coming year as
a PhD student one thing I want to
improve on that I think is important for
grad students is to read a lot of papers
in my field of research I think that's
sort of really important to stay at the
top of your field and to know what's
going on I know one of my supervisors
said to me that when a student finishes
their PhD or when they're towards the
end the difference between a good and a
bad student is that the good one has
continuously read lots of journal
articles over the course of the last few
years whilst the bad student is trying
to catch up on all that reading so to
avoid being the bad student I do want to
stay up-to-date with what's going on in
my field I think another thing that's
important to think about as a grad
student is the need to publish your own
papers so it really depends on the field
that you're working in but there's kind
of an expectation that you have maybe at
least three or four first author papers
to your name by the end of your PhD
program that would indicate that the
work you've done is novel and is a
significant contribution so I want to
hopefully this year or at least in the
first half of the year as well get my
first published paper out so there's one
I've worked on the manuscript of already
and I hear that the process of maybe
editing and going through a peer review
is quite lengthy so we'll see how that
hopefully I can get that out as soon as
possible a third thing that I want to
remember to do this year is to be brave
so there's a lot of things that I think
can be quite scary about being at the
study of PhD or being a grad student and
that's trying to set up collaborations
emailing people that you don't know and
asking for things doing a lot of
emailing and just also meeting people at
conferences talking to people and really
sort of knowing what to ask for and not
being shy to talk to people that are the
top of their field they're not being
intimidated by them I feel like I was
quite brave last year and I want to
continue that because at least for me
it's not always so easy I feel like I'm
a really shy person and even have a bit
of social anxiety in a lot of settings
but I think the only way to overcome
that at least for me is to continue to
do things that I would consider brave
feel free to share your resolutions for
the year with me whether they're
academic related or personal I'd love to
hear what other people are trying to
work on and I hope you have a great 2018